China's plan to reopen its borders next
year continued to make a big impression
on investors on Wednesday Asian markets
were in particular about what it might
mean for Global inflation
and that China wants to repair its
economy in 2023 is hardly a secret It's
Quickly removing pandemic measures and
promising economic stimulus
and next year also marks the 10-year
anniversary of Beijing launching its
belt and Road initiative XI jinping's
massive infrastructure building plan has
also faced hard times from defaults to
delays to Growing skepticism among other
countries now it also has competition
from the EU and G7
at the Port of Hamburg almost every
third container comes from or goes to
China in order to remain attractive for
large container ships from the Far East
Germany's largest seaport wants to build
more berths for giant Freighters the
money comes from Chinese state-owned
Costco Shipping Company
brought a 24.9 stake in one of the
port's four terminals two months ago
Costco had already acquired stakes in 14
European ports but in the wake of
Russia's war in Ukraine the Hamburg deal
came under Fire many lawmakers in Berlin
fear Chinese access to critical
infrastructure and that the project
could lead to a problematic dependency
akin to German Reliance on Russian gas
tensions between the EU and China were
already growing amid beijing's sharper
nationalistic turn and its suppressive
policies in Hong Kong and the western
region of xinjiang
for its prestigious Belton Road
initiative China finances infrastructure
projects in 140 countries for almost 1
trillion Euros the EU is trying to
counter this with a budget of 300
billion euros
for its own project called global
gateway the European Union aims to
invest in infrastructure projects in
emerging and developing countries with a
focus on sustainability Environmental
Protection and Fair competition
criteria that play no role in China's
Belton Road initiative
is our correspondent in Taipei chechwan
the belt and Road initiative was
conceived of as this kind of Jewel of XI
jinping's foreign policy but we've seen
that his fortunes have changed or been
challenged in recent years and
especially since the pandemic what can
we say about it right now
yeah so right around you know Stephen so
far we see no signs that China is going
to shape the this foreign policy away
you know it's worth noting that
2023 March 10th anniversary of this
initiative and just few days ago China
mentioned that in 2023 many are looking
forward to the third belt and row forum
for international cooperation and before
that Chinese president Xi Jinping he
also stressed to European that China
welcomes the eu's participation in belt
and Road cooperation for greater Synergy
with the eu's global gateway strategy so
we can see that China is expected to
push forward its Belgian Road still in
the upcoming year
uh we mentioned that port in Hamburg
Costco's bid for a stake in that
terminal divided the German government
are more countries wary of Chinese
Investments or are they maybe attracted
to it during these tough times
yes Stephen indeed more and more
countries are actually worried that
Belton wrote initiative might be poison
coated with sugar and except for the
handbook cast that you've mentioned a
lot of key incidents is Sri Lanka's
bankruptcy this summer as a rouse
widespread awareness of the potential
risk of China's debt trap diplomacy and
in this month Saudi Arabia and Palestine
have separately announced to deepen
their cooperation with China's Belton
Road initiative while she's visiting
their country so you know it's still
very hard for those countries to say no
to such an attractive investment from
the second largest economy in the world
we've heard a lot about Western attempts
to answer the belt and Road initiative
to what extent can European and G7
investment really approach the levels of
Chinese State spending is that even
comparable
yes you know it's really hard to say but
some experts sees 2023 might be a good
time for the Europe you know to compete
with the Chinese uh Belton
Belton Road initiative because uh you
know China is now facing Kobe and
economic troubles but at the same time
EU has also been faced with some doubts
it's been a year since the project has
been announced but according to the
excerpts sing by the media with
president of the European commission she
said in a recent meeting that the global
gateway project still suffers from lack
of visibility recognition and some
visible heart infrastructure projects
and besides Ukraine war and the debates
within the EU members may also hinder
the progress of flip projects so we can
say that in 2023 the competition between
EU and China might be uh heating up but
it's still unclear who's gonna be the
winner
all right that's cha Chun yeah in Taipei
thank you